what's up everyone welcome back to the
collider interviews YouTube channel for
another interview this is with one of my
favorite working cinematographers out
there Robbie Ryan the cinematographer
behind poor things and at least one
other movie that I will squeeze in a
question about today hello Robbie nice
to meet you and congratulations hello
Perry thank you very much you lovely to
be here so as I teased my first question
is not about poor things I am slightly
obsessed with Medusa Deluxe I have to
ask you one question about that I'll go
broad with it I want to know the single
most challenging sequence to photograph
in that
movie
uh there I guess the because it's sort
of like pretends to be one shot but we
are we always endeavored because we shot
over nine days it wasn't one shot
obviously but we endeavored to try and
do uh you know the longest takes we
could so I think the first take the very
beginning of the film goes on for about
a half an hour so that was probably the
biggest challenge and you know it was
the most fun because you're kind of like
there's a what I like about um I don't
like a lot of things about one shot
films I can tell you now but what I do
like about it is the the theatrical
aspect of it where everybody has to be
on point not only the camera or the
sound or the you know everybody includ
mainly the actors need to get it right
and it's kind of fun watching how actors
adapt and don't sort of go any another
take
because they know they have only got
half an hour and if they kind of mess up
within that 25 minute part of that half
an hour they will feel pretty like you
know bad and as all of us would so that
that was a challenge but that was kind
of like the fun challenge um I guess
technically it was
always uh you know the biggest challenge
for me in a way was every other film
I've ever done I was the operator on but
this film obviously is all steady Cam
and I don't do steady cam so um the we
obviously tried to get somebody who was
suitable who had you know a good
technique but also was able to be strong
because it's a long process and who was
maybe a little bit because we're low
budget somebody who's maybe doing it for
the first time so we got this really
great guy called Jake White House and he
was a lovely sort of steady cam guy but
the challenge was for me to prove to him
that he could do these shots because I'd
be like rehearsing it with a camera and
okay we do this we do that with Tom did
director and then Jake would go I can't
do that I'm like why can't you do that
and he had this AR steady cam rig and I
you know I I would know so much about
camera movement but with that AR it kind
of it does it in a different way so I
was having to learn how he would be able
to achieve something or like why he was
saying he wouldn't be able to achieve
and that was that was a process I wasn't
expecting that movie is something else
the only reason why I'm able to pull
myself away from talking about that is
because poor things is also something
special I'm just hoping that all the
conversation that is likely to be had
about your work in poor things also
inspires people to seek out some of your
past films in particular Medusa Deluxe
which needed a larger audience than what
it got it deserved it it did deserve it
it just fell through the cracks a little
bit unfortunately yeah but it's a it's a
fun one yeah and uh he's very
interesting director Tom amazing I am
very eager to see more from him all
right poor things now or actually a
broader question to start here so you've
worked with some pretty incredible
directors over the years do you find
that the directing greats have a shared
quality you appreciate but then also
what is something about your ghost that
makes him one of a
kind yeah I I first of all I'm blessed
to have been able to work with people
have worked with I'm been so lucky you
know it's it's a it's a real I don't I I
pinch myself most of the time to go well
how the hell did this all work out but
um I guess the fact of the matter is all
those people are have worked with have
all been really kind of like you know
gracious as far as how to let me work
within their world and kind of let me
into the world of they're shooting and
like some directors like Ken Lo would
have had a style very much from the
GetGo and I kind of I sort of figured
out what that was and he was kind of
like let me do that within a very
patient way um but uh you know all of
this stems back from my work with Andrea
Arnold because I think I wouldn't be
anywhere without her and she sort of
kind of was we we know we're peas in a
pod in a way we kind of have a lot of
connection and you know the things we
like most about Cinema are similar so
she was totally kind of brought me on as
a kind of after her short film was we
kind of like started really you know
enjoying figuring out how to do the next
ones and we just have a really great
Shand now so um you know those are
directors who I guess gave me freedom
and then working with yorgos like yorgos
is definitely
um you know he has similar ways of
letting me be free but at the same time
I'm trying my best to figure out what it
is that is the the world of yorgos and
like he's he's really unique there's
nobody quite like him as a filmmaker I
think because of his um his aspect on
how he sees the the cinema he wants to
make is very like there's not he's got a
great sensibility and I I always feel
kind of like wow you know there's not a
film Yus hasn't seen there's not a actor
he wouldn't know and you know he's
really got a definitive idea of what
he's doing but at the same time would
happily not know what he's walking into
a room to do and then figure it out so
there's always a contradiction there's a
lot of contradictions in his Cinema and
in his approach and I don't want to say
contradictions but there's an you know
he's an enigmatic director and it's a
it's a real joy to work with him because
he really likes to have a an environment
to be creative I love hearing about that
all right going back to the very very
beginning when he first pitched this
film to you what would you say is the
biggest difference between how you
pictured it looking on day one compared
to the finished film that we're all
going to get to see soon uh well the
first time yor mentioned this film to me
was what the we were at the screening
for the favorite and thenis and I said
what do you what's what's happening next
what's on the cards he because well I'm
thinking about making a film about a
woman who wakes up with her baby brain
in her head I was like that sounds about
right that sounds right up your street
yeah good I would love to be involved
with that if that happens you know and
uh so Denny sent me the script um and I
remember reading it really like you know
with a lot of enjoyment and trying to
figure out what the hell because every
scene just seemed to be fairly you know
Full Tilt full volume and crazy and uh I
was like wow I don't know how how is all
this going to fit into one film and you
know that from that to when we started
filming uh to the final film I think it
kind of punched above its way and got
close to what the script wanted it to be
you know there's not many scenes that
aren't in the film that aren't are in
the script I think very
few most impressive literally every
single ounce of this movie I feel like
takes the the visual style in particular
and many other aspects of the film 2 and
11 and uh I can't I can't believe how
full such a lengthy Journey for this one
character feels it's really quite the
accomplishment for a mere two hours and
20 minutes it is it is absolutely that
and it's um you know down to the fact
that Emma Stone is like just so
wonderful to watch that the you know
it's been kind of crazy this last few
couple of months since the premier in
Venice that we've been as a craft sort
of Team we've been out promoting the
film a lot and obviously with sag on
strike the actors aren't allowed to do
that so we've almost kind of become the
promoters and we kind of always I always
kind of like go yeah yeah yeah blah blah
blah blah but then you're just gonna
have to repir it back to how absolutely
phenomenal Emma's performance and all
the actors supporting her are and they
they make the film so real and it's it's
in quite unreal way I am quite eager to
get the actors in on this
conversation I also quite enjoy the the
crafts people getting this time in the
spotlight because you all deserve it
more than you get it well I think as far
as this film Goes The Craft side of it
is quite um you know really creative and
there's a lot of lot of stuff to talk
about craft wise and um I'm I'm I'm
totally happy to talk about it all right
so I want to get into one particular
part of the process which I hear was
unique for you the the idea of getting
to build this world from scratch so I
have a couple questions about that first
can you give us an example of something
we see in the final film that you know
would never have been possible had you
not been involved in that element of
this this production so early
on uh I think all of it's like that
really it's um you know everything was a
construct so uh and considering with
something like the favorite me and Yus
made uh was a completely location based
film this is a you know all of a sudden
you know up to the production designers
to create the world in front of us and
the costume designer and makeup and hair
obviously so like as a cinematographer
it's always what's in front of the
camera so I'm I'm kind of like not doing
much different to what I would do on
other films it's just sort of the things
that are going on in front of the camera
and poor things are quite elevated and
and really really you know kind of
interesting to film um but as far as the
process me and jorus go through the
cinematography kind of is not a million
miles away from poor things but it was
just a joy to be involved with how we
could incorporate our camera moves
within the sers James and Shona would
work from a a um computer program called
unreal uh engine and blender and these
are two sort of like very high-end sort
of 3D programs where you could see the
whole set in its uh digital format and
like you could walk through it in a 3D
way you could really see every aspect of
it and we could kind of adapt it before
it got built so I do think jorus uh was
very keen on this piece of uh software
because you could kind of like build it
knowing that it was going to be what you
wanted and you know as close as what you
wanted so like for instance when we
walked into the the set that was the
ship it was like exactly how we' looked
at it as a 3D program and it was like
quite un you know unreal to sort of walk
into something that we've been looking
at for ages on a computer because we
were filming in another set for a long
time so they built this the ship set
while we're filming on Baxter's house
like Dr Baxter surgery and stuff like
that so that was all like taking up a
lot of our time so from the time we'd
been prepping the Unreal Engine blender
stuff to when we walked on were like
kind of a bit of a gap so I never really
saw the ship fully built until we'd
finished the other set and it was like
wow it was like Christmas day you like
walk in and this is this is the thing
You' been seen on a a computer screen
for so long but it was in your it was
like tactile and tangible whether it's
using software like that or any other
element of this process is there
something new and specific to pour
things that you think is going to
influence your work on other film going
forward where you're going to want to
take that technique with you well
they're all old techniques ironically we
like all the old stuff like um shooting
on film for one is to feel like an old
sort of technique but it's having a bit
of a it's hanging in there it's like
it's like vinyl records but um I think
within that Niche I I would say me me
and jorus really were fond to of the
vistavision format we kind of shot on
that for some of it and that's a very
old format which was made in the 50s it
was a kind of Alfred Hitchcock a lot of
his films were shot on this one
particular camera and it's called a
vistavision camera and because our
aspect ratio is 166 uh Vista vision's
aspect native aspect is 166 also so that
was kind of like oh this is something we
should try out and um we would have done
more of it but it was unfortunately a
very noisy camera so um for syn sound it
was difficult to do that and we yogus is
very keen on getting his sound on set so
we only used it for like stuff like the
reanimation sequence and I like going
for forward I would absolutely love to
do a film on this division but it's kind
of going backwards Le forwards if you
know what I mean yeah I I definitely
understand that the challenges that come
with it all right I want to get into a
couple of very specific scenes first
first I'll tackle that a little more
broadly of all of the really ambitious
scenes and set pieces you have in this
movie going into filming which did you
think would be the most challenging to
photograph and then ultimately was that
indeed the toughest of the bunch or did
a different scene catch it by surprise
no no the toughest one for me uh and I
felt it coming and then when it happened
it was that one it was the um when Bella
goes to Lisbon and her world is like
turned upside down in this kaleidoscopic
space and the set that they built was
like huge amazingly like elaborate sort
of two quadrants of Lisbon pulled out of
Lisbon and recreated in a studio in
Hungary and like it was an epic stage
really and uh obviously involved having
to approach it with more lighting and
and create a sunny environment but like
mix it up and the the main reason I knew
it was going to be a challenge was
because all of our our filming was in
one studio in Hungary but the build of
this other place where they shot Lisbon
where Lisbon was getting built was in
another Studio which was like a two-hour
drive away so we just didn't get to see
it enough that's my my post-
rationalizing of this is that we didn't
get to see it enough before we got there
and I wasn't able to drop in on a
regular basis uh enough and it just felt
like it was always going to be an uphill
struggle and it it turned out to be such
but you know it was still an amazing
thing to film it just was a little bit
more difficult I love how you're like I
didn't get to do this enough and what I
see is like stunning one of a kind I
don't know how you pulled it off I'm
glad that's I'm glad that's the case
yeah no but we we felt that was um I
think all of us had a bit of a kind of
like a bit of a hope struggle with that
particular World well whatever struggles
she powered through it was well worth it
so now once specific scene that I
absolutely have to ask you about please
walk me through the planning of and the
filming of the dance scene in this movie
and how did that compare to filming the
dance scene in the favorite which is
also kind of iconic well um yeah I think
the dance scene in favor sort of prepped
me enough to know what was coming with
that and like Yus works with his um
choreographer called constanza and she's
like really fun and she kind of brings a
great spirit to her dance routines and
like Mark Ruffalo and Emma Stone like
trained certainly for like a good week I
think I don't know how long they worked
with conans on it I don't think they
they had that much time to work on it
but they just brought so much to it and
it was like because we were in the thick
of a lot of filming that was sort of
like okay we're on to the dance sequence
now let's get on with that and I I I
know that they done a lot of rehearsing
on it but you know maybe still not
enough rehearsing and my main concern on
on that scene from a camera point of
view was that I wasn't going to knock
down any with the other dancers because
we were kind of up there with them
filming amongst other dancers and you
know the camera's like going around on
this small stage in a way and you know I
always was a little bit concerned that a
big lump of metal was going to hit
somebody but we didn't thank God and uh
yeah I I find um the choreography and
that was really fun so that that really
again being in front of the camera made
me look you know it looks like we knew
what we were doing but really the secret
is in the way the dance was
choreographed it is absolutely stunning
I am eagerly awaiting the day when this
movie comes out and hopefully that dance
becomes the next hot Tik Tock Trend I
just need that in my life right now yeah
like they did it great yeah they did it
a lot of times as well it was like it
wasn't it wasn't a oneoff I can tell you
that much it is so perfect and it just
like so speaks to their characters and
what they're going through in the moment
too which just makes a moment like that
even more effective and the ending of it
is hilarious when she throws the the
glass at them yeah it's got a lot of um
real good comedic moments and uh you
know good dancing oh yeah oh yeah very
impressive right there all right now I'm
gonna ask the most evil question I have
on my list because I'm essentially gonna
ask you to pick your favorite child do
you have a single favorite frame of this
movie a lovely question to ask I I
always talk about this one because I I
love it because I I love a a happy
mistake in a film and um in the
reanimation sequence in it's in the
trailer um there's um the bit where she
kind of wakes up finally uh uh and the
camera we we had was on a roster like
was above her and uh it was that old
vist division camera and it I I I I it
wasn't a great camera because it kept on
sort like it was a bit of a Frankenstein
camera in its own way and it was running
out of um Power or like whatever
happened the batteries ran low on it so
when it was filming her uh it kind of
slowed down and when you slow a camera
film camera down the the the effect you
watch when you see the results is that
it's being up ironically because it's
going like so just at the time where she
opens her eyes it kind of slowed down
and she kind of opens her eyes in a
weird sort of like unreal way and I kind
of feel that's perfect for her so I've
I've always s like been fond of that
shot a lot it's been a question I've
been eager to ask is that Pure
Performance or something else because
something just seems
so like she's like and it's it looks
like it's shot backwards but it's not
it's shot fors but there's a camera slow
down which made her blink open sort of
quicker unexpected movie Magic is the
best kind of M I love it love it all
right I gotta let you go soon so I'm
gonna ask about one uh future film
because clearly I love when you
collaborate with your ghost and I hear
the two of you have already made another
film together I don't know if you're
allowed to tell us anything about that
one but maybe can you compare the visual
style of that film compared to this and
also the favorite uh well I think it's
been said already so I'm not going to
get into trouble because I thought I got
into trouble already about letting out
things out of the bag on that one but I
think jorus mentioned it at the Venice
Film Festival so I'm allowed to say it
and we uh yeah we shot for favorite and
poor things on spherical spherical
lenses so it's kind of like that sort of
aspect right show but the next film is
shot with a widescreen aspect so it's a
anamorphic film so that's that's
different in a lot of ways right from
the geeko and um yeah it was it was
really enjoyable process and it's it's
it's it's a different film for sure to
poor things not many films are like poor
things smaller right smaller
scale uh uh yeah I don't know it's it's
a bit more bigger it's it's bigger in
other ways but it's it's um it's
certainly not like we built every set no
it's got on location there's not so many
lights so uh yeah it was if that means
it's smaller yes it was more yeah well
like what does mean
production anything you two work on
together sign me up appointment viewing
you never disappoint congratulations
I'll get you on the guest list congrat
I'm there congratulations on poor things
and I cannot wait to talk about it for
months to come and also years to come
because clearly it's a movie that I'm
equally obsessed with as Medusa Deluxe
and the favorite keep telling people
about Medusa Delux oh I plan on it I
plan on it that's so great you love that
brilliant I will tell Tom that thank
you